[Music]
i think some of the
damage i did is probably permanent as
far as like an
enlarged heart yeah i don't want to go
back and bodybuild i'm not looking for
that i'm looking for
you know how long can i live right i
mean if you look around this
office who's here it's old men it's like
why am i here
i'm freaking 37 like something's wrong
right
jeff has been under the care of a
cardiologist for the past year
ever since doctors treating his steroid
infection
also discovered signs of heart failure
so doctor because jeff took testosterone
for so many years
now his body doesn't produce it
naturally and he actually has to take
testosterone
to stay healthy this is the the
unfortunate irony for guys that are
looking to
become superhuman per se now they end up
in a point where
again they obliterate their body's own
ability to produce testosterone
today jeff will be getting the results
to see if his heart
has bounced back to normal so there's
there's two main things that we're
evaluating with that echo one is your
systolic function which is the squeezing
function and that was the one that was
mildly reduced last time
you were here that actually does not
look
significantly different okay so it still
looks a little bit sluggish
but there's another parameter that we
look at which is the
relaxation function of the height right
and that was also quite
abnormal last time you're here that
looks significantly better okay
okay you know we're not we're not at the
point where i'd say your heart looks
normal unfortunately
right i think you should sort of get
your mind around the fact that you're
probably going to be on long-term
medication
i worry about just longevity his heart
actually hasn't bounced back to normal
and the longer we see it
that sort of suggests that something
permanent has happened there
and if he started taking steroids again
not a good idea
we've heard from a lot of people that
say that there's a safe way of doing
this the people that have gotten hurt is
because they didn't know what they were
doing
and they were taking too much or right
but there is actually a safe way to do
this right what do you think
i think those people are kidding
themselves the best data that we have
are autopsy studies that means someone
died
jeff frankly is lucky there's lots and
lots of case reports of
young guys having heart attacks and
having strokes sudden death
so your first symptom is dying
[Music]
you